ihre themenvorschläge wie whatsapp sind
einfach super auch das folgende video
gibt es auf ihre anregung hin und zwar
geht es um die rodung des hambacher
forst ein wald in nordrhein westfalen
mittlerweile das symbol des widerstands
der anti kohle kraft bewegung gegen die
zerstörung der umwelt durch die
kohleindustrie doch worum geht es
wirklich wer hat recht und wie wichtig
ist braunkohle für unsere
stromversorgung die wichtigsten fakten
zu diesem ultra wichtigen thema jetzt
bei klick zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen wir wollen dabei sein könnt
erfahrt ihr am ende des videos die
bilder sind wirklich hoch dramatisch mit
mehr als 2000 polizisten die den
hambacher forst räumen sollen handelt es
sich um einen der größten
polizeieinsätze überhaupt in der
geschichte von nordrhein westfalen am
donnerstag 13
september 2018 ging es los mit dabei
feuerwehr sprengstoff expertinnen und
experten und spezialeinheiten
schließlich laufen die einsätze in
großer höhe von bis zu 29 metern ab hier
kann jeder handgriff ein leben kosten
konkret geht es darum 120 vielleicht 150
aktivisten und aktivistinnen aus ihren
rund 50 baum äußern soll
doch es sind lange nicht mehr nur noch
diejenigen aktivisten und aktivistinnen
die sich schon seit langer zeit für den
alten wahl zwischen köln und aachen
einsetzen auch andere demonstrantinnen
und demonstranten haben sich auf den weg
in die region gemacht dabei mussten die
umwelt aktivisten und aktivistinnen in
der letzten zeit eine juristische
niederlage nach der anderen einstecken
in einem eilverfahren hatte das
verwaltungsgericht köln am donnerstag
die beschwerde gegen die räumung durch
die stadtgärten zurückgewiesen auch das
oberverwaltungsgericht münster hatte
dann den stopp der räumung abgelehnt es
fehle an baugenehmigungen und
brandschutz für die baumhäuser nach
angaben von rwe sei es noch in diesem
jahr dringend nötig den hambacher forst
roten denn nur dann könne man die
kohleförderung und den tagebaubetrieb in
den kommenden zwei jahren aufrecht
erhalten ohne die rodung drohe das
erliegen der förderung und das würde rwe
teuer zu stehen kommen es geht also um
eine menge geld denn die
kohleverstromung macht analysen zufolge
etwa 70 prozent oder mehr
der stromerzeugung von rwe aus vor etwa
40 jahren wurde der tagebau erschlossen
und das rheinische revier in dem das
areal liegt gilt als größtes
geschlossenes braunkohlevorkommen in
europa 38 millionen tonnen braunkohle
wurden alleine im vergangenen jahr
gefördert damit wurden 15 prozent des
strombedarfs von nordrhein-westfalen
gedeckt dabei ist von dem ursprünglichen
bald schon beinahe komplett alles von
der bildfläche verschwunden 4100 hektar
groß war er mal vor beginn der
kohleförderung 3900 hektar sind bereits
gerodet worden jetzt sollen eben auch
noch die verbliebene 200 hektar wald auf
weniger als 100 hektar abgeholzt werden
auf die gefahr hin dass auch das image
des unternehmens leidet doch das scheint
es jetzt wohl wert zu sein das resultat
daraus dass sowohl eon als auch rwe sich
lange zeit nicht auf die aktuelle
entwicklung wie die energiewende und den
atomausstieg vorbereitet hatten
seine ökostromtochter innogy hatte rwe
erst vor zwei jahren an die börse
gebracht so will man langfristig dann
wohl auch auf kohle verzichten bis dahin
aber noch die profite mitnehmen die der
hambacher forst in form seiner
braunkohle so bietet um das übrig
gebliebene waldstück herum zum pagan sei
technisch keine option so rwe und so hat
sich der konzern auch gegen das ziel der
kohle kommission gestellt
zusammengesetzt aus verschiedenen
vertretern und vertreterinnen der
bereiche politik umweltschutz und
industrie im auftrag der bundesregierung
sollte für den herbst ein konzept
vorgestellt werden wie man gemeinsam den
ausstieg aus der kohle schaffen könnte
das starre vorgehen von rwe in diesem
zusammenhang sehen so nicht nur die
umwelt aktivisten und aktivistinnen
kritisch sondern beispielsweise auch
wirtschaftswissenschaftlerin wie etwa
die energie expertin claudia kemfert vom
deutschen institut für
wirtschaftsforschung in einem interview
mit dem deutschlandfunk wir können sehr
viel schneller aus der kohle aussteigen
als manche jetzt sagen und je schneller
wir das tun desto weniger muss man auch
in hambach roden und braunkohle abbauen
insofern wäre es schon ratsam gewesen
man würde die diskussion der kohle
kommission abwarten und dann erst zur
tat schreiten
wir haben ja hier darüber berichtet laut
einer fraunhofer studie ist der frühere
ausstieg aus der kohle ohne probleme
möglich den link gibt es am ende des
videos und in der video beschreibung
zurück zur kohle kommission
denn eventuell hätte die kommission ja
entschieden dass der tagebau gar nicht
mehr abgebaut werden muss darauf hatten
die umweltschützer und schütze rinn
gehofft unter anderem der bnd der noch
im april diesen jahres geklagt hatte
schließlich seien die kriterien eines
europäischen naturschutzgebietes gegeben
doch gerichte haben entschieden und so
ist der innenminister von nordrhein
westfalen davon überzeugt das zitat sich
der staat durchsetzen muss schließlich
sei akute brandgefahr gegeben ja das ist
jetzt plötzlich so wichtig dabei gibt es
die baumhäuser im hambacher forst in
denen sich die aktivisten und
aktivistinnen verschanzen schon
jahrelang sie rufen der polizei entgegen
wenn ihr kinder habt dann lass den
unsinn eine klare botschaft denn längst
ist der kampf gegen die braunkohle auch
zu einem kampf um die zukunft unseres
planeten geworden denn die braunkohle
gilt als der schmutzigste energieträger
überhaupt im vergleich zur erdgas
beispielsweise hat braunkohle einen rund
60 prozent höheren ausstoß von co2 zur
folge schon deswegen fordern viele
umweltverbände den sofortigen ausstieg
denn wie will man sonst den pariser
klimavertrag und die ziele der eu
erreichen
bis 2030 soll der co2 ausstoß demnach um
40 prozent gesenkt werden im vergleich
zum jahr 1990 der ausstieg aus der
braunkohle ist zwar politisch als teil
der energiewende beschlossen doch der
konkrete zeitpunkt noch nicht und trotz
ihrer ganzen nachteile hat sie als
energieträger kaum an bedeutung verloren
die zahl der beschäftigten im
braunkohleabbau ist trotz des
beschlossenen ausstiegs den letzten
jahren konstant gestiegen und auch der
verbrauch ist im vergleich zu anderen
auslaufenden energieträgern kaum
zurückgegangen zwischen 2005 und 2007
von 54,5 auf 51 5 millionen tonnen heißt
also auch nach der energiewende hat die
braunkohle eine große bedeutung für
einen energiemix und so ist der ausstieg
alles andere als effektiv im gange ganz
im gegensatz zu dem ausstieg aus der
kernkraft und der steinkohle das problem
sowohl die beschäftigten als auch die
unternehmen leisten wie
der stand und aus der politik gibt es
offene unterstützer was damit bei meist
übersehen wird ist die tatsache dass
braunkohle längst nicht die günstige
energie ist für die sie oft gehalten
wird laut einer studie des
umweltbundesamtes also des
umweltbundesamtes staatliche
institutionen sind nämlich die
gesellschaftlichen kosten bei der
stromerzeugung aus stein oder braunkohle
besonders hoch 2016 sind dadurch
gesellschaftliche mehrkosten von rund 46
milliarden euro entstanden und zwar
konkret durch umweltkosten durch
luftschadstoffe wie feinstaub oder
schwefeldioxid oder eben durch das
klimagas co2 diese kosten sind eben kaum
offensichtlich denn unsere gesellschaft
bekommt sie nicht über die stromrechnung
zu spüren finanziert wird das ganze an
anderer stelle nämlich durch höhere
beiträge für steuern oder krankenkassen
beispielsweise die umweltbehörde rechnet
vor dass ein geordneter kohleausstieg
somit milliarden einsparen würde und
nicht nur dass strom aus wind oder
solarenergie seitdem nach schon heute
deutlich günstiger
drei mal günstiger als strom aus kohle
dazu der energieexperten oliver krischer
von den grünen fraktion im bundestag in
einem interview mit der deutschen welle
die folgen des co2 ausstoßes für die
klimakrise die gesundheitsschäden durch
quecksilber feinstaub und stickoxiden
die umweltschäden durch das abholzen von
wäldern und das abpumpen von grundwasser
sowie die kosten kaputte häuser und
straßen durch bergschäden werden einfach
auf die allgemeinheit abgewälzt und
tauchen in der kostenbilanz des
braunkohle stroms nicht auf nur deshalb
ist braunkohle strom an der börse billig
die zeche zahlen gerne und damit zurück
zum hambacher forst er war lange zeit
einer der größten mischwälder europas
und hatte trotz seiner wirtschaftlichen
nutzung ein einzigartiges ökosystem zu
bieten
außerdem hat er eine mehrere jahrtausend
alte geschichte denn es gibt ihnen seit
der jüngsten eiszeit vor 12.000 jahren
das alles lässt sich nicht mehr
zurückholen
und fest steht auch im oktober darf rwe
dann offiziell mit der rodung beginnen
wir machen hier etwas mit etwas
positivem weiter ihr könnt klicks um
werbefrei machen wir haben ja schon
angefangen immer mehr videos sind
werbefrei dank eurer hilfe immer wenn
wir entsprechend viele kanal
gewonnen haben schalten wir die werbung
vor allem video habt werdet also
mitglied hier unter dem video
draufklicken und ihr bekommt noch
exklusive extra videos live streams und
noch ein paar weitere privilegien für
einen kleinen beitrag wenn er immer
garantiert über aktuelle videos
informiert werden wollen dann endet mich
übrigens bei whatsapp da könnte auch
themenvorschläge machen
dann bekommt ihr den link übrigens zum
video vor allen andern von mir
persönlich auf euer handy einfach hier
draufklicken und da drunter geht es
weiter dafür auch draufklicken mit dem
thema so kann deutschland seine
klimaziele doch noch erreichen
bis dann bleibt dran